sont pas bien belle les voir important
c'est qu'elles soient bonnes quand
c'était le père de votre mari qui les
vendent elles n'étaient plus à betty
scoop une fois que vous aurez payez
votre dette la vente de la maison bleue
sera suffisamment d'argent de
recommencer quelque chose c'est qu'ils
ont c'est tout ce qui me reste
tu fais tout ce que vous m'avez dit
franchement qu'est-ce que je peux faire
de plus pourquoi tu étais en tête
tiendra pas tout seul
je suis là je t'aime beaucoup plaire
avec tous les réglages et je vais pas
encore plus me coller un mec sur le dos
vous voulez que je vous emmène à
l'hôpital non je ne bouge pas vous
pouvez pas rester là je ne bouge pas je
reste là vous êtes les commentaires pas
très pratique vol hier à paris j'aime
pas partners le pôle c'est moi j'aime
pas les suites qui ce mec d'où il sort
la gelée royale contient de
l'acétylcholine indispensable à
l'érection particulièrement efficace
dans l'entretien du bon fonctionnement
des organes sexuels
il est différent non il y aune est
fiable fidèle et il ne veut de mal à
personne en effet les différents de la
plupart des gens
pour ça que je ne suis pas normal qu'on
peut pas débarquer dans la vie des gens
comme ça c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe
quand il aime il passe deux tribunes
elle m'a nommé pour évaluer les risques
il va très bien il n'y a aucun besoin
d'être soigné
qu'est ce que vous regardez les nuages
il vit les choses beaucoup plus
intensément que vous et moi
vous pouvez pas rester vous êtes têtu
bordélique bluffé joly
amoureux de la mer moi je pense que tu
es amoureux de la mer